if you're watching this thing you know
by now a huge problem is heading our way
an emergency meeting is being called our
usual place immediately free bagels
i've made a shocking discovery
i needed to get me in touch with nasa
immediately well nasa and i aren't
really on speaking terms these days or
that'll change
when you tell them that the moon is out
of orbit
there's no need to panic not facing
why are they lying about all this
it's too late to stop
you knew all this was happening before
nasa
you're the unidentified source oh yes
we're dealing with an intelligent entity
we're planning a mission to attack this
thing
i'm asking you for your help
say yes brian
i need you to be brave
if the moon really is what you think it
is
suit up
horizon you have got a big gravity
weight coming your way you have to
launch now did he say gravity wave
trouble
we're underwater guys
that's crazy
[Music]
what's the plan save the mill and save
earth
it's flying itself
wait for it
let's go use sonoma
everybody hang on i'm gonna get you home
[Music]
it's on airplane mode
[Music]
[Music]
you